[Music]
hi think about the lift we got by moving
from rule-based systems to machine
learning what if I tell you that we can
get an additional lift with causal
machine learning
for example in a marketing campaign by
identifying customers for whom sending a
coupon will increase engagement
my name is Adi I'm a research scientist
at PayPal
and in the past year and a half I dived
into this fascinating world of causal
inference and causal machine learning
and I'm happy to share with you today
what's in it for data scientists
what is causal machine learning It's a
combination between causal inference and
machine learning causal inference is a
fast-growing field with strong
mathematical foundations in causal
inference we strive to learn cause and
effect patterns from data while in
machine learning we learn statistical
patterns correlations
in machine learning we mainly seek a
mapping
between features X and outputs labels y
in causal inference we introduce a new
Central component to this formulation T
the treatment or action we take and one
of the main tasks is to estimate the
causal effect of t on the target
variable y
remember the coupons example so
estimating the causal effect of sending
a coupon to a customer on her engagement
can help us identify the best target
audience for our marketing campaign
where is the machine learning so machine
learning models are integrated within
the causal inference framework
and they are helpful especially with big
and high dimensional data they are
estimating actually intermediate
quantities within this formulation
causal effect estimation is being used
by many industry leaders in their
applications and it's already providing
business value and one evidence for that
is the great availability of python open
source packages that um
that are implementing these methods
okay so it's great to see Kaza machine
learning already provides us business
value but not every data science use
case easily fits into the causal
inference framework
so fortunately
causal machine learning work streams uh
there are they are very interesting
causal machine learning work streams
that solve more General data science
challenges
as data scientists we usually train a
machine learning model which is then
being integrated into a broader
decisioning system that takes actions to
improve some business kpis
one of the main challenges one of a
challenge okay not maybe not the main
but a challenge of um such correlation
based models is they're out of
distribution generalization when the
data distribution in production differs
from the data distribution during
training time models performance can
deteriorate
causal machine learning
um gives us a very interesting
perspective and there are many works
that utilize ideas from causality to
tweak the training process
to learn
um to do what is called Kaza
representation learning to reduce the
effect of spurious correlations and
train overall a better generalizing
model
another challenge comes when we try to
design a policy on top of an already
trained machine learning model
can we optimize a personalized policy
end-to-end from features to actions
for example in the fraud detection case
given transaction features should we
approve or decline this transaction
considering our fraud prevention kpis
cause a machine learning approach for
policy learning provides us a framework
to explicitly or implicitly
um estimate what would happen if we take
each of these actions in order to
optimize an overall end-to-end policy
for a conclusion
one thing I would like you to remember
is that that causal machine learning is
already providing us business value
we talked about causal effect estimation
the potential of causal representation
learning and policy learning
obviously there is no magic
it takes hard work to learn the theory
to get to know your data generating
process and to evaluate these methods
without a ground truth
being invested in this field in the past
year and a half I really encourage you
to experiment and learn about causal
machine learning I believe this way we
can leverage its potential realize its
potential and overall bring the business
value lift we are always looking for
thank you so much for listening I would
be happy to continue this discussion
later
foreign
[Music]